I accept our Michaels Kapoor apology
he's apologized to me for leaking the
mammal and he's accepted that the
contents of the Mabel wear and true and
pleased about that you know I don't
think there's any place the election
campaigns for dirty tricks like this I
think we should fight election campaigns
on the strength of our ideas and our
policies not by engaging in smear
campaigns or dirty tricks but what I've
also said city is I think you know it's
not just me Alistair chemicals and
apology too in fact that's probably not
the most important apology that he
always I think he was at apology to his
constituents not so much for leaking the
mammal but for seeing in the election
campaign that he didn't that he knew
nothing about it that the first I knew
about it was when he got cold by a
journalist about it that's the basis of
which people were asked to vote for him
and no of course we find out that he
wasn't being entirely honest when he
said that that he was the one who leaked
it so I think he was them an apology and
well honesty is a trade that many people
wish for in politicians again having
said what you have he is the only lib
dem north of the border Lib Dem MP won
by just 817 votes would you like to see
a rerun do you think he should stand
down well you know that's a matter for
him I'm saying he should consider his
possession and reflect on the fact that
you know he didn't put his hands up to
this during the election if he had done
that then the voters in his constituents
he could have gone to the pools and
possession of all the full facts and
made their own judgments and they might
sell a 44 and we'll never know that but
you know it's at least possible is it
not that had they known the full facts
they might not have 44 them we'll never
know but it's at least possible that
that's the case but you know I think he
does all their money exploration and all
they have an apology for my part I
accept his apology you know very soon
after this story broke in the election
campaign it was established by both me
and the French ambassador that I hadn't
said what I was alleged to have set it
so that wasn't in doubt the question was
who leaked this memo and why did they do
it and I'm is still enough ice to
Jameson if I can just interactions dead
there is still another question because
the inquiry did find that they had no
question no reason to question the truth
of the
in fact they say it was recorded
accurately now at the time you said that
what was said in this memo was a hundred
percent untrue you standing by that or
did you actually say that you would
prefer David Cameron in them in number
ten no no no I didn't see it absolutely
categorically not but my key point is
you don't just have to take my word for
that the French ambassador who I was
speaking to says that I didn't see that
but you know I think you've slightly
misrepresented what the Cabinet Office
report said they didn't say there was no
question over the truth of the member
what they said that I accept this was
that the civil servant who wrote the
main will water in good faith they
thought they had accurate recorded what
the head but if you recall that civil
servant also said in the memo that the
accepted that it could have been lost in
translation so no I didn't you say that
because it because I was guessing you're
suggesting that a civil servant wrote
something that was a hundred percent
inaccurate so what did you say about
David Cameron and EDD Miliband in that
meeting them because the the memo that
was least was saying that you would
prefer mr. Cameron to be the leader of
conservatives and remains Prime Minister
and the memo also claims a circle ed
Miliband was not prime minister material
so how was that law in translation what
you'd have to ask the French Consul
General in the civil servant one MMA
there is no doubt that i didn't see
these things well there was a general
discussion of it the election but you
know if two people have a conversation
and both of these people say that
something wasn't said then I think that
should be the end of the message
definitely I think she didn't he didn't
say anything else fazer David Cameron
like this number 10 Isaac sounds like
you were in favor of that I didn't have
written it down how could that have got
lost in translation general I see I
didn't see that I see her didn't see at
the French ambassador says I didn't see
no I accept that people and I regret
this by accept that people me sometimes
not want to see the word of a politician
on things but the French ambassador says
I didn't see it there is no question
about that part of this I'm a politician
that has spent my whole political
kittiya campaigning against
conservatives and conservative
governments the idea that I wanted to
see another tory government is absurd I
was all throughout the election campaign
seeing to Edmund
and if we had the numbers we should come
together to lock David Cameron and out
of Downing Street okay so we've come to
we've come to the end of the the general
election can make the general election
campaign has happened the general
election has happened in there are 56
smps MPs in Parliament and David Cameron
is back in number 10 are you happy with
that situation how it's all ended I'm
not happy with David Cameron been back
in number 10 absolutely no I wanted to
see David Cameron a note of number 10
but labour wasn't able to beat the
Tories in England and that's why the
Conservatives are back in office but 56
SNP MPs yes I'm very happy about that
because that means Scotland can have a
loader voice in the House of Commons MPs
who will stand up for Scotland against a
Conservative government and progressive
MPs who will seek to build progressive
alliances with others across the UK so
that we can continue to be a voice
against austerity and for stronger
public services that's what that big
team of SNP in pieces and the House of
Commons to do and of course they've
managed to secure the first adjournment
debate and the House of Commons next
week on the important issue of trident
and some of the safety concerns our own
Trident they have been expressed in the
last few days okay Nicola Sturgeon thank
you very much to speak he says here on
Sky News this evening thank you thank
you very much